All right--so let's do some swapping. So, here's how it works.
We start out at the root where the problems is and we say "Okay."
Well, what's the smaller of the two children and that's the 25
and we're going to need to swap the 50 and the 25 to fix things up at the root.
We've bubbled that 50 down just a little bit.
But now, we've created--well, kind of things are okay over here but not so okay over here.
So, 50 is smaller than 56 but not in 26.
We're going to have to swap 50 down with the smaller of it's two children.
So, 50 and 26 are getting swapped. All right, so now, what horrible thing have we created now?
Well, actually, things are pretty good now.
This 50 is actually happy with respect to it's children, and if you're paying attention
to what's going on elsewhere in the tree, everything is okay now, all right.
Because we didn't actually touched this sub-tree.
It had the heap property? It still has the heap property.
We've bubbled the 50 down into here but we only pushed it to the right.
We didn't mess with this sub-tree, so that one is still okay.
And now, for more it is right now, everything is fine.
We've now established the heap property everywhere and 50 ends up in node 4 here.